people that want to
to learn and feel that they are
developing in their
work and and have passion for what you
do the biotech industry
really
is best suited you you learn every day
something new
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i have with me the club
justice axel broad executive vice
president and chief financial officer of
poly pid a global clinical stage
biopharmaceutical company focused on
developing manufacturing and
commercializing novel locally
administered therapies to improve
surgical outcomes before joining poly
pid seven years ago she served as cfo at
both compute gen and packet technologies
and as audit manager at earnest and
young israel she holds an mba in finance
and a ba in accounting and economics
both from tel aviv university and is a
certified public accountant in israel
so thank you very very much for being
here and i'm really really excited and
honored uh to talk to you today all
about you know surgeries bacteria both
from a financial standpoint but also
just from from a world standpoint uh
your your journey is a fascinating one
and the work that you're doing today
with polly pitt i think is so incredible
uh from what i was able to understand
it's so complicated but i'm excited for
you to dumb it down for me and share
with me and my audience a little bit
about what it is that all of you are
doing which literally is saving lives so
decla maybe take me a little bit
throughout your own journey and how you
end up as the role of executive vice
president as and cfo of this company
so i
to start with i want i knew from very
early on from from childhood i want to
be
in this position i want to be in leading
position
with
companies that are
meaningful meaningful and successful in
many ways in
successful economic successful in terms
of the environment that they are
operating employees
and i don't know exactly why but for
some reason i thought that
having a strong financial background can
open the door for me to to get
fairly quickly fairly
easily nothing is easily but to get to
those position and and i started
knowing that i have no intention to work
in this occupation to i've started
learning in university economics and
accounting
and i registered to this to this va
knowing that i have no intention of
becoming
an accountant in a firm i literally knew
that
and i remember
very
strongly how at the first day in the
interim
i
was working in one of the big five it
was at the time now it's the big four or
big three it's changing very rapidly and
it was one of the well not one of the
leading insurance company in israel and
i was put in
into in front of this
book that looked like that and said this
is the cash check it
and this was the cure for me
that this is not not what houston we
have a problem i would say and i
transferred to ernst young to to be with
with the high tech and this was the
2000 before before the bubble burst it
was the
the end of
it was
checkpoint were
one of my
clients
deal time that became shopping.com
the spg really the
days of the early
tech and it was wonderful to see those
company to see
people in
in different position of these companies
from
ceo to bookkeeping
feeling passionate about what they do
and and it was clear to me that i want
to be
part of this uh
industry
uh and i've started in in this area but
very quickly i moved on to to the
biotech
and for me
the biotech was was
in a way love at first sight i would say
it's much more challenging it's much
more uh
the the processes are
much longer term it's not you don't
build a company
uh in a year and in the year after you
sell it right 4 billion
it's not happening in the biotech
company
industry you sometimes work for 10 years
to get the product and a drug to to
approval not sometimes usually this is
the time so you have to be much more
patient i'm
i'm joking and saying that it's a
you need to be
able to
deal with mania depression because
some days you are
within mania everything looks like
you're going to conquer the world
and few days after
things are not progressing results are
not looking good
and it's it's literally like that almost
sometimes on a day-to-day basis
sometimes on a week-to-week basis
and this is this is how the the moods
are changing
um
and and and for me
it's
it's so passionate to be in this
position because you know being a
financial person and being a cfo i could
be in any company it could be in
gaming company i could be in
construction i could be in insurance i
could be in banking but being in biotech
and being part of the team that the
leading
the company into developing drugs that
could actually save that life and change
situations that have been an unmet need
for for years i'll give you an example
polypede is now focusing is now in in
two phase three
trial
the last stage for approval of a product
with the fda and the european
authorities
for a product that we hope will show
significant reduction of surgical site
infection
ssi a problem that has been around
for
from from early days infections are
something that that has been around
forever and will continue to be around
bacteria is there and people are going
to surgery
usually we
with three concerns one that there will
be some complication in the operation
but they
usually trust the surgeon that they've
chosen
and they put themselves in
in his or her hand
they are afraid of complication
and pain
and complication are usually infection
or in many cases are infection
and this could be a perfect surgery
everything was done perfectly the
surgery room is perfect everything is
perfect but
the bacteria is out there it's on our
skin it's in the air it's on the surgery
it's in the surgery room it's on the
surgeon's
hand and we can't really do anything
from prevent it what we can do
is make sure
we create a gatekeeper from the bacteria
to grow along the incision and this is
so before before we dive deeper into
polyp and what the company does take me
back a little bit into your own entrance
into biotech because you know biotech is
one of those verticals where there's a
very high barrier of entry you have to
have a lot of expertise to to understand
it and to feel empowered by it
how how are coming from a financial
background what was your entrance into
the biotech world like was it simply
choosing
to to be a financial executive at a
company that happens to be doing biotech
or was it or was there some other
connection that has led you to this
so i'm joking that
my mother
has a degree in biology and she was a
biology teacher in high school and my
father has an economic degree and he was
a ceo in the food industry and i had to
please both so i ended up finding myself
in the bio industry amazing and i think
that
to be more serious i think that
people that want to learn and feel that
they are developing in their
work and and have passion for what you
do the biotech industry
really
is best suited you you learn every day
something new biology is is an area
different from
computer science that is not fully
understood there is more and covid now
out there really teaches us a lesson
about that
the unknown is greater than the noise
which i don't i think we cannot say the
same about physics
and math
and computer science biology
there is still so much that is unknown
if the if we were
in terms of science as developed as we
are
in computer science probably we've
solved most of the diseases we're not
there
we are getting there a lot of
influential saying that
this decade is this is the decade of of
life science
of biology
so being a part of this industry being
part of coming in the morning and and
learning something new about our product
is what is that it's doing it it's not a
question of whether it will
sell
right we know it will sell the question
is whether it's work right there is work
as we are hoping for which is very
different from very different from
traditional yes you you develop
something
yeah yeah if you develop something you
know you you'll be able to solve it
you'll need more
engineer hours you'll need more things
to fix and bag in this program
but you don't know if sure there will be
a market for it we know there will be a
market
tell me a little bit about the role of
the role of a financial executive
within a biotech company with all these
considerations in mind right because
here you don't necessarily you know
dealing with the same
things that a traditional cfo of a
startup would deal with but but what
what what does this role include really
both in the day-to-day but also in the
strategic long-term thinking
uh so i'm quoting with someone much
smarter than i that said that the cfo
is no it doesn't stands for chief
finance officer
in
innovation company but it stands for
chief focus officer
and and uh
it's it's very much the case but i i
would add to that
that in the biotech industry
the um
the one thing that is missing more than
anything else
is funding because this is a long
journey because this is a journey that
will take years
you need to find it along these years
and you need to create a strategy a
finances think strategy that will
support
the company while it's private and then
while it's pri public and then
also while it's public you funding
doesn't end at that point you need to
you want to bring another product to the
pipeline
you want to go to cancer you need to
have a strategy for funding and the
relationship with the investors and the
banks is something that it's a
day-to-day relationship
right that makes a lot of sense so now
going going back to poly pit tell me a
little bit more about you know starting
more with the pain point that poly pit
is trying to solve with what's happening
today with site infections and surgery
so today
you if you look worldwide you see that
about
five percent of the patient in average
that goes to surgery will have some
level of infection
and sometimes it's not that is that is
not uh
this is this five percent these are
infections that shouldn't
ideally take place obviously these are
infections that take place because of
because of what reasons because of the
the actual surgery the surgery think
about it very simplistically
someone is having a surgery
they the skin is cut the muscles are
scat
the
sometimes the bone is cut depending of
where the surgery this cut
creates a
two things on one hand you cut the blood
supply to the area
so you do not have blood supply to the
area during surgery and
a few days after that means that your
immune system cannot get to the area
well
and treat any intruders that are coming
from the outer
so on one hand you have an opportunity
for the bacteria to go in
you you opened
the body but you do you
stopped
our defender our immune system to
getting to the area
and in a lot of surgery you have some
level of infection after that it could
be very simple it could be some redness
some secretion from the wound some fever
a patient get antibiotics and
everything's well
but in other cases it could lead to
mortality and disability especially
in the big surgeries and
patients are also having some
what we call risk factors and those will
be
older people smokers
people with high bmi and
diabetes those patients have higher risk
for infection and this could literally
lead to disability
and mortality
right right and so how we are trying to
so so so what we we are doing is very
cool actually uh our founder and cto dr
norm emanuel has developed
a concept a platform that
can encapsulate and release almost any
drug locally think about an onion
his structure
we're talking about granola in the size
of a salt
that our structure from thousand ten
thousand layers
and if you think about an onion with ten
that every few minutes the outer layer
disintegrates and the drag is released
this is the matrix that we call plex
this is our platform our unique
platform
we have over 100 patents around it and
what we've done initially is taking this
this platform
and peering it with antibiotics
so what's happening in the body patient
is having a surgery let's say open heart
surgery cabbage surgery last stages of
the surgery the chest is open everything
is good now the surgeon is closing the
incision before closing they apply our
duplex 100
it's it looks like a paste the drugs
looks like a paste very easily with the
gloves
and gradually the antibiotic is released
along the incision for four weeks so
every few minutes and now a new outer
layer is disintegrate and the drag is
released again and again and again and
this creates very high local
concentration along the incision
without influencing the microbiome
without any stomach exposure so you have
maximum exposure where you need it
and nothing that goes into the
whole body
right that makes a lot of sense now tell
me a little bit about how you know
length how long does it take to build
something like this 100 patents you know
a really complicated solution what is
the life cycle of a company like poly
pid
and and where is it headed now
so
you you're touching a very good point
because
it's taken us several years to first
build the platform wow i'm not talking
now about product
validate the platform in different
indication
also during these years having some
collaboration with the large biotech
companies the u.s large biology
companies to test the platform in in
different application
and about seven years ago we've decided
to focus and establish our own pipeline
initially as i said focusing on surgical
site infection
and now we are very close to approval we
are in months time from getting our top
line result and then submitting them to
the fda
not
just a few months ago at the end of last
year we've announced our second inline
product that is
peering the platform with chemotherapy
for brain tumor same concept local
chemotherapy
avoiding the systemic exposure of
with all its side effects
as well as enhancing the therapy which
is what what we are here for to bring
best in class therapy
wow very very cool now the cloud take me
a little bit about your own personal
journey again and and i'd like to
understand you a little bit better from
childhood you mentioned that you knew
that you wanted to be an executive in a
company and that you thought finance the
financial route would allow you to to
make that to barrier of entry and i love
how you're translating the cfo to chief
focus officer not just dealing with the
financials but what really sparked your
curiosity as a child that also led you
to this understanding
so
i think i
i
literally remember myself
daydreaming imagining myself
in this in the chair that i'm sitting
now now of course i didn't know
what it would look like and what this
chair will be and what this position
but i think i
i felt or i knew what the feeling should
be
what the feeling should be or might be
and i tried to visualize that this
journey as a child as a and
and what really
intrigued me was to be in a position
where you
you can lead people you could be part of
the team you could be in these
points in a company that makes a
difference makes a difference in in the
industry that i am i think which is the
best it actually saves life what who
could who could say
that that what they're trying to do is
save lives so that's very inspiring
right and i think that obviously that
that answers the the second question
about the inspiration today and and what
are a few words that you would use to
describe yourself
as your as as you're going for your own
journey
so i would
i must say
or i must start
probably with the
persistency
and creativity
and and one will think that those two
words somehow contradict themselves
but i think you have to be very
consistent
with your path
with and clear with your path with your
life you could say life
journey
and very creative on the day today and
and for me this is what i hope i
how i live my personal life and my
career always consistent and persistent
on
the long term and the past but very
creative on a day to day
and what i strive for and most of the
day i feel this way is passion
to have passion with what i do
that's very this is something that
that
most of the day i i can say i'm
passionate about what i do not all of
course but most of the day
well it definitely comes across in how
you describe what you're doing and i i
wish for myself that when i'll describe
what i'll be doing throughout my life
i'll do it with a similar passion and
and intentionality is as you've just
done in this last 20 minutes and i
really appreciate your time decline
thank you for making a positive impact
and and i can't wait to see this product
in action best of luck with the with the
last milestones for getting this
approved and it sounds like this is
going to make a tremendous impact on a
lot of lives and thank you for your time
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you very much same to you and
shanatova